I'm going to teach you
how to plan your dream
wedding, but on a budget.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Mindy Weiss.
And with my years
of experience, I'm
going to share all the
tips to wedding planning.
I've got you.
From your guest list,
invitations, attire,
photographer and
vendor selection,
to even your food selections.
At the end of this class,
you're going to feel confident
planning your wedding.
Here's a tip: a sip of
champagne is much more expensive
than a glass of wine.
Skip the champagne.
You're going to walk away from
this class with your wedding
binder that will have all
the details of your day
because an organized
couple is a happy couple.
[MUSIC PLAYING]